good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 8:47 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 8:47 is to be kept in a reinforced
modified humanoid containment chamber
for the purpose of ongoing behavioral
studies the room is to be fully
furnished with a bed dresser couch
table chair full-length mirror sink
shower and toilet the floor of the
chambers to be constructed with one
centimeter exposed beams of copper which
can be electrified remotely to a minimum
of 50 kV potential a 50 centimeters
squared safe zone at the right rear
corner of the containment chamber is to
remain free of copper beams in the case
of personnel inside containment during
disabling of SCP 847 no meals are to be
provided
all personnel posted to SCP a 47 must be
armed with a shock baton rated at 30 kV
or greater only men which has been
stricken from the document XY males
identifying as such are to be assigned
to or permitted within a 50-meter radius
of SCP a 47 after the results of
experiment 847 G upon order of the
ethics committee intersex transgender
and non-binary personnel are prohibited
from working with handling or
approaching SCP 847 for their own safety
and well-being when assigning personnel
to SCP 847 preference is to be given to
men who were not sexually attracted to
women description SCP 847 is a human
female mannequin 156 centimeters tall
and 27 kilograms in Mass constructed of
human hair and an unknown composite
fibrous polymer that braids and shatters
similarly to porcelain exploratory
laparoscopy of SCP 847 shows the
presence of internal structures
resembling
an incomplete set of bones organs and
major blood vessels composed of the same
polymer small amounts of black volatile
resin similar to plastination compounds
leaked from the eyes and damaged regions
of the mannequin
SCP 8:47 has always been which has been
stricken from the document is normally
at some level of disrepair with
shattered areas on the torso head and
limbs see addendum 847 B for details SCP
847 is animate and moves with erratic
stiff motions while shuttering to
maintain balance it demonstrates
different behaviors depending on that
Jena typical sex and identified gender
of nearby humans these behavioral
patterns are grouped as pattern Z
pattern y and pattern X pattern Z
behaviors occur when there is no human
within 50 metres SCP 8:47 remains
inanimate and silent 99.5% of the time
under these conditions when animate a
CPA 47 will dress in any available
clothes stand in front of any available
full-length mirror and return to an
inanimate state adopting a pose that
showcases the outfit worn it favors
clothing which is designed for young
women and which leaves ample skin
exposure on rare occasions SCP 8:47 will
scratch short messages on nearby
services with a finger or depending on
the state of repair with an available
appendage messages written since
entering foundation custody are found in
addendum 847 see pattern y behaviors are
adopted when there are male subjects but
no female subjects within 50 metres
independent of intervening obstacles
initial stage behaviors involve emitting
vocalizations resembling high-pitched
whimpering gasps and adopting more
provocative poses occasional shudders
can be observed during this time
after three to five minutes of the
initial stage as CP 847 s behavior
enters a secondary stage during which it
becomes fully animate approaching any
male subject adopting a hunched pose and
appearing to look up into the subjects
eyes vocalizations during this period
become more frequent and in longer
duration subjects are able to handle and
freely alter the pose of scp-804 t7
during this time when posed it holds the
new pose as balance allows the final
stage of pattern Y behavior occurs
approximately five minutes after all
subjects have left the 50-meter
parameter of SCP eight 47 it will then
shatter select portions of its body
and/or extract internal structures once
shattering or extraction is complete it
emits sobbing vocalizations and returns
to patterns EB havior x' pattern x
behaviors occur when any female subject
approaches within 50 meters independent
of intervening obstacles whether male
subjects are present or not SCP 8:47
will emit vocalizations resembling
distressed grunts and screeches
immediately animate and physically
attack the woman during pattern x
behaviors a CP 8:47 strength and speed
are greatly increased with Sprint's of
up to 45 km/h an exertion of forty kilo
newtons of force having been measured
during an attack SCP 8:47 will
occasionally shatter an appendage
usually a finger or a toe in order to
produce a sharp edge furthermore
plastination resin is released from its
eyes mouth and shattered sections of its
body resin falling in open wounds
results in a quick hardening of soft
tissues that spread until the victim's
body reaches a composition of a similar
polymer as SCP 8:47 following
plastination SCP 847 will harvest
selected body parts from the victim
corresponding to the damaged sections of
its own body it will fuse these parts to
its body via the
not all damaged sections will be
repaired in this way upon completion of
harvesting as CP 847 will return to
pattern y or pattern Z behaviors the
resin produced by a CP 8:47 has been
shown to have its anomalous plastination
effects occur only when applied to soft
tissues of women the resin has no effect
on cadaverous non human or male tissue
application of high-voltage electricity
in excess of 10 kilovolts will cause a
temporary solidification of the resin
resulting in SCP 847 becoming inanimate
for approximately five minutes
regardless of the behavior pattern
expressed at the time addendum 847 a
recovery lung a federal human
trafficking investigation led to the
discovery of scp-804 t7 in the basement
of an abandoned department store in Las
Vegas Nevada on August 23rd 1983
surrounded by partially disassembled and
broken non-anomalous female mannequins
wrapped in plastic sheets FBI agents on
the scene witnessed SCP 847 exhibit
pattern Y behaviors initially thinking
it was a trafficking victim agents moved
in to assist SCP 847 then switched to
pattern X and attacked one of the agents
the agent subdued a CB 847 with her stun
gun leading to the discovery of
high-voltage electricity as a tool for
containment and was evacuated from the
basement the unusual incidence unit was
informed of the situation Foundation
agents were contacted through regular
channels and SCP 847 was secured despite
signs of human habitation trafficking
victims were never found
addendum 847 be shattering event law
notable shattering events are listed
below
due to the shattering and harvesting
behaviors of SCP 47 it has significantly
altered appearance since entering
foundation custody see photos and log
for different stages of completion date
August 27th 1983 description of event as
CP 847 shatters chest after researchers
leave containment researchers nose
researcher was hurt to verbally note
unrealistic proportions in the
containment chamber during initial
placement researchers are advised to
avoid any verbal commentary regarding
SCP 847 while in the containment chamber
replacement harvested September 12 1983
date May 14 1984 description of event
SCP 847 shatters notes after experiment
847 e with DAT 334 researchers notes as
part of regular testing protocol
subjects are not informed of SCPA 47
shattering behavior after the subject
leaves the containment chamber see
partial debriefing interview below is
there anything about the appearance of
SCP a 47 that you particularly noticed
you mean other than being a living
breathing mannequin well nose looks
funny you know how those nostrils just
flare out like that they're just tense
not covered nicely did you say anything
regarding a CPA twenty sevens nose to it
nothing she's not someone you can talk
to doesn't talk back but doesn't listen
either
replacement harvested October 20th 1984
at the conclusion of this harvest female
d-class testing with this EP 8 47 was
prohibited on the order of the ethics
committee date April 21st 1995
description of event SCP 847 tears out
all head hair and extracts liver after
experiment 847 J with D 13 928
researchers notes see partial debriefing
interview below did you make any comment
than a CPA 47s hair please answer the
question
you got it all on film ah I didn't see
much of anything
I was just hella impressed with an
actual living doll real fun piece ass -
I suppose I can't take her drinking
though being plastic at all and he's
still locked up of course well thank you
d13 9208 we're done here well he said we
could run this experiment again sometime
hair replaced July 13th 2013
liver replaced August 12th 2013 date
March 1st 2005 description of event SCP
847 tears out all pubic hair during a
period of pattern Z behavior researchers
notes of note is that it is the only
shattering event that has not been
linked to a pattern Y period SCP 847 is
not attempted replacement date September
23rd 2013 description of event SCP 847
extracts brain eyes clavicle and
shatters hands researchers notes SCP 847
had become fully intact under researcher
Tyler Jensen's supervision in the
interest of reducing SCP 847 s
capabilities a test was authorized with
d70 294 chosen because he had been
convicted of multiple murders of a
sexual nature shattering event lasted 45
minutes with a CPA 47 emitting novel
screeching vocalizations throughout
partial debriefing interview follows D
72 94 please state your opinion of a CPA
47 cute don't explain please elaborate
and we squeals and growls it knows what
it's there for
but it does allow Z job in what way it
doesn't follow orders yes you could pose
it humiliated but it doesn't do much
more than you or linea I had to break up
a finger just to see if it matter it
didn't you know it's ironic you dream
your entire life of finding a woman
who's that compliant that devoid of
thought that helpless to your every whim
and when you find her she's just a
useless mannequin who can't do anything
thank you DSM D do an ID for we're done
here
gods please escort D 7784 back to his
cell addendum
847 C message log below is a log of all
messages written by NCP 847 to date
while in foundation custody
attempts to communicate with SCP a 47
have met with failure as CP 847 does not
use words when vocalizing and does not
respond to questions asked by personnel
whether spoken or
August 25th 1983 come back October 13
1984 I can do better
March 9 1986 where are you
May 18th 1988 where is Mike Prince July
21st 1990 I can change October 5th
1996 you can only February 12th 1998 you
were my master
June 8th 2008 when T fifth 2004 whatever
you want April 15 2009 1979 to 2009
April 16th 2009 to old April 17th 2009 I
can be young for you December 3rd 2011
what's wrong with me
March 8th 2013
I'm sorry I'm worthless August 31st 2015
daddy I'll be good
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Mookie Jax Merrick Caleb
Bowen slump God John Porter captain
Gorge Tiber ball
Judi Dench cheese whip dips McGee I'm
dr. mortis thank you so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you